well this morning we're getting a more
complete picture of an encounter caught
on video between a police officer and an
eight-year-old boy in syracuse new york
newly released body cam videos revealed
what the officer said before the
confrontation that left the boy in the
back of a police car nancy chin shows us
what the officer told the boy and his
father after they brought him home
where are you going
didn't we just go through this from the
first moments of the newly released body
cam video you were crying in the
backseat of my car
remember that the officer asserts this
is not his first encounter with the
eight-year-old boy who he says he caught
stealing a bag of chips
as he attempts to pull the child of his
bike bystander kenneth jackson arrives
and confronts the officer
get off your bike in what syracuse
police say was a low point the
interaction between officers jackson and
another bystander grows heated you all
take to jail you want to take the jail
you i will take to jail him i'm taken
home on another body cam we see the
sobbing child struggle as an officer
puts him in the back of the patrol car
he grows inconsolable
the boy's cries continue as an officer
drives him home
where police give their account to his
father that's what they do every day is
they go to stores and they steal stuff
while i'm sleeping
in the morning this kid fall out of this
house i know where they've gone through
this is like the beginning of it so
they're gonna start doing
more and more
criminal things
an officer then talks to the boy and his
brothers about being friends
even as he warns them to stay out of
trouble i don't want to be seeing you
guys like this again i'm happy to say hi
to you boys in the street and talk but
i don't want to be tracking you down
because you're stealing from people
again but thursday just four days after
this conversation syracuse police
confirm the eight-year-old was ordered
to appear in juvenile court charged with
patty larceny for allegedly stealing
another child's bike
for cbs mornings i'm nancy chen
you know i know a lot of police officers
and police unions that didn't want body
cameras but i think in this type of
situation to then be able to see the
other side
of things and how things worked out this
is one of those times i'm sure they're
glad they had them on yeah well you know
there's
i think the the intent was we're going
to scare this kid straight um but you
know that's it's complicated when you
see it on camera yourself and i guess
this is where you're going to have a lot
of people
looking at you know what's next yeah
it's a tough situation on all sides and
that kid's got a you know some changes
to go through before adulthood hopefully
he makes some changes